Hey Thoughty2 here.
Walmart is the largest company in the world,
and the biggest employer in the U.S. pulling
in $469 billion in revenue every year.
Out of the top 7 revenue generating companies
in the world, Walmart is the only one that
doesn't deal in oil and gas.
In fact every year, everyone in the world
will make an average of 1.1 purchases at a
Walmart store.
Walmart has 2.1 million full-time employees.
That's seven times the population of Iceland.
In 2012, Walmart registered approximately
$444 billion in sales, which is $20 billion
more than Austria's GDP.
If Walmart were a country, it would be the
26th largest economy in the world
If Walmart was an army, it would have the
second largest military in the world, behind
China.
Walmart is bigger than Home Depot, Target,
Sears, and Costco combined.
In 2009, Walmart sold more bananas than any
other item.
If Walmart's more than 900 million square
feet of retail space were spread out over
one place it would take up roughly 34 miles,
which is about 1.5 times the size of Manhattan.
Walmart parking lots alone take up roughly
the size of Tampa, Florida.
In 2000, Walmart was sued 4,851 times, or
about once every 2 hours.
90 percent of all Americans live within 15
miles of a Walmart.
The most frequent destination typed into Telenav
GPS devices is Walmart.
Roughly 4,700 (about 90 percent) of international
stores operate under a banner other than Walmart,
including Asda in the UK, Seiyu in Japan,
and Best Price in India.
An additional Walmart Supercenter per 100,000
residents increases average BMI by 0.25 units
and the obesity rate by 2.4 percent.
8 cents for every U.S. dollar is spent at
Walmart.
On average, about 100 stores go out of business
in the area surrounding a town with a new
Walmart store.
Walmart's CEO Mike Duke makes sure to keep
his employees paid, but that doesn't mean
he doesn't keep some for himself.
In 2010, his $35 million salary caused him
to earn more in just one hour than the average
Walmart employee makes in a full year!